what advice do you have for anyone
preparing for their first burning man
even if they're not going to film
they're just going there
yeah don't go there and film right
that's the advice is
is go there to experience it i think um
you know us trying to do a documentary
at the same time as we're trying to have
our first experience there
was rough uh it was rough because you
always feel like it's
in competition you always feel like you
want to be filming but you want to be
experiencing
and it's hard it is very hard to have an
experience
and to film it too and i feel like
the documentary projects that i've seen
have shot amazing documentaries
but i don't know if they've experienced
it while they were filming and i feel
like our documentary is that
weird fine line between okay you're with
the filmmakers you're with the
experience as much as we possibly could
i feel like that's what we produce here
is is
you know this sort of like you're
experiencing it in their shoes
you're seeing them you know you're
that's the
fascination with bringing so many
cameras out there is we really got the
cameras with
the people that were experiencing it so
if you're going to go out there
check out some packing lists there's
amazing packing lists that people have
like
created of like what to bring dust masks
water food you know tent you're gonna
you know baby wipes you know things that
are like oh well i wouldn't have thought
about
that well you know bring this bring this
and those
packing lists are now amazing and you
can just sort of like go down list and
it's like a camping trip except it's a
party too
except you know there's it's like a
museum because you're checking out all
these amazing art projects
you know so it's like this it's an
amazing mixture of stuff out there
so but it sounds like it's also more
than just that it's where people kind of
go to like
find out certain maybe like shadow parts
of themselves and then heal them or i
don't know
am i just imagining part of that it's a
full range so
there are theme camps there that are
dedicated to people's
spirituality or dedicated to people's
uh love and emotion or um
you know past experiences you know or
letting go a big thing out there is the
temple
you know that's something that a lot of
people connect to out there because
basically it's like this opportunity
where people can
forgive themselves uh um acknowledge
loved ones
that have passed away or maybe past
experiences
it's sort of like a you know
you go through an experience and you're
a different person on the other side and
a lot of people
come away with like a profound uh
journey that they they've taken
out there and how long do people
normally stay
the festival is a week uh you know it
opens
uh monday morning sunday night and goes
through monday
so it's it's seven eight days a lot of
people are there for
nine days there's a bunch of um
dpw the department of public works that
actually build the city they put out the
streets they make sure the
infrastructure is correct they put up
the street signs
they run center camp and those guys are
out there for months
for months a couple years ago i got to
go out there
before the opening so i was out there
for an extra 10 days before the event
started
and it's just fascinating being out
there before the arts there
so you literally see nothing and then
art projects get created
as as you know boom
burning man's open and people are
scrambling to try to get their projects
finished
out there's it's um yeah
and what temperature ranges are we
dealing with uh it's cold man
at night time it can get cold it can get
below freezing so
30 30 degrees fahrenheit at night all
the way up to 110 115 degrees
in the sun during the day it gets hot
that's why people don't wear much
you know it's it's it's hot and free and
you want to just be out there
experiencing it so
make sure you have sun protection and
drink a lot of water
do's and don'ts yeah do drink
do drink water do participate interact
with people experiencing it
you know there's no judgment out there
which is a fascinating
like thing because like people are weird
there are weird people out there so
don't
think like you're gonna be judged
because there's weirder
like you know what i mean like go out
there and just
uh enjoy it and be fascinated with it
and you're going to meet some
fascinating people
you're going to meet i mean i've met
i've met some
fascinating people out there what if
you're shy and what if you're sober
and you don't want to it's not studio 54
in 2013 and you're going to go there and
you're like you have a social phobia
yeah that's the perfect opportunity uh
sober yes
uh i don't drink it all so um
you know you can have an amazing time
out there and not not be drunk
not have alcohol in your system there's
people out there that
just are there to embrace the sun
every morning the sun rises out there
and it's just
weird some days you think like
it's going to be the end because the sun
is so big on the horizon
there's so many people that are just
gathered around it
like a couple years ago i just shot
these amazing sunrise photos out there
was like hundreds and hundreds of people
welcoming the sun
and it's and okay you've been up all
night so you're awake for the sunrise or
people get up for the sunrise
but yeah it's just a beautiful beautiful
beautiful time out there
and you're bringing your own food yeah
it's it's a weak
uh self-sufficient that's one of the big
the big things about burning man is
self-sufficiency so
people team up people uh come together
as
theme camps or camps and they do food
together
so you have a team of 20 people that's
what we did we had a
we had our own camp that we made we were
inside videogasm camp
which supplied us with like a sink and a
shower
and stuff like that but all of our
cooking and food
we all did ourselves and sink so there's
running water
sort of so different camps will have
these massive hundred gallon tanks
they'll bring in
where they'll have a shower set up so
you can take your two minute
you know shower off kind of thing
i'm thinking camps have hundreds and
hundreds of people kidsville isn't a
great example kidsville is like a
collection of
families from all over the world and
they have one of the largest theme camps
there i think there's three or 400
people
that all come together and camp in
kidsville
you